what did for the love of George teach
you about screenwriting I mean it really
taught me the whole process to be honest
because this was my first feature it
really taught me you know it's very
different when you when you write a book
or a story I'm really aware of how
pacing is so important and dialog is so
important and how my co-writer has a
tendency to make things really wordy and
I'm somebody who does not particularly
like wordy films you know like Woody
Allen is a great all his films are
extremely worthy and so yeah you know
visual is very important you know
locations are very important you have to
think when you're writing you're not
just write you know you need to be after
it needs to translate into film right so
it just basically taught me the whole
process you know how to make a movie it
all begins with a good script and it's
so important when you start writing it
that it can't just read what it has to
translate on the screen what does it
teach you in the sense of completing
something or the idea of something and
then the actual time and energy it takes
to do it you know sort of taking the
mystique away from oh I'm making a movie
and and and how exciting it sells but
also how stressful I'm sure it can be
yeah I mean people you know even now
people say well that's great you made a
movie and you know when you're in the
middle of it it's like I mean obviously
none of us would be in this industry
doing this if we didn't enjoy it and it
wasn't something you wanted to do but
you know for me there were so many
struggles and so many problems in the
producing sign of it and you know so
many curveballs like that the engagement
that happens and you know even just you
know financing and trying to get a
director and having producers sign up
and then drop out and it was just so
much and it just you know it really kind
of taught me that I mean there were days
when basically I wanted to give up and
thought this just isn't worth it but you
just get up and extend you keep going
and it really kind of made me realize
that if you're passionate about
something you know
there is an ending to it and it's
then you can be really proud of it and
you know to now look back and think you
know I did this feature and it started
it's just this little idea and you know
I'm proud that it was my first feature
that I've written the first screenplay
the first film I produce the first film
one really played a feature that I
played to lead in like this so but you
don't really but for me I didn't really
I'm just kind of realizing it now now
it's out some people are watching it you
know because I think until then you're
just so caught up in all the having to
get it finished having to get it made
you know there's always and someone was
saying to me you know at every level
like you can make a fifty million
hundred million dollar film there's
always problems you know from a
producing side there's always things
that come up and you just have to learn
to deal with them and I think for me now
I've learnt so much on this film like
hopefully the next one is going to be a
little bit easier because I think I've
faced almost every problem you can face
for making a film but you know you can
get through it and as long as I think
you have the passion and the
determination and you don't give up you
know it's worth it it is worth it I now
have a film you know which has
distribution yes which has distribution
and people are watching and you know and
you seen the reviews come out and it's
like something I made that people are
actually enjoying it know because you
get so caught up in trying to make it
good and the sound and the edit and the
distribution and everything that goes
with it you kind of forget what drove
you to make it in the first place and
the whole vision and seeing at the end
and seeing that people are actually
enjoying it it's a really good feeling
have you always been a finisher or you
know how some people start many things
and then they end and have sort of
undone for various reasons or are you
always make do you always make sure you
finish everything you start I mean I'm
not someone that starts loads of
different things that you know I have to
be really passionate about something to
actually get so involved in it but if I
am then I will always finish it you know
like that there might be things and like
I
I always want to get going with things
so if I have to sit and read a contract
like for example I hate board games
where you have to read the rules let's
just make them up as we go I don't sit
there and read like a whole rule book
let's just make them off and you know
that's the kind of thing I just kind of
flag it
and everything but if it's something I'm
really passionate about I think I always
I'll always see something to push to the
end I hate you know I hate not having a
an ending and having something half done
I want to do it wholeheartedly if I if I
something actually want to do
you